Speaker 1: Now let's go from Hannity to another
Fox News propagandist, Tucker Carlson.
How is he reacting to the Russian invasion
of Ukraine?
Well, he's doing it by siding with Vladimir
Putin, as Vladimir Putin quite literally was
invading Ukraine yesterday.
Tucker Carlson came out and said, Hey, Ukraine
isn't even a democracy, it's not even a democracy.
Implicitly justifying the Russian invasion,
here is Tucker.
Last night,
Speaker 5: Ukraine is not even a democracy.
Despite what Joe Biden endlessly claims, Ukraine
is a corrupt Eastern European autocracy that
has spent millions of dollars lobbying politicians
in Washington and, by the way, made Joe Biden's
family rep.
Speaker 1: OK, so Tucker isn't wrong in the
sense that Ukraine is a corrupt autocracy,
but Russia is even more of a corrupt autocracy.
So justifying the more corrupt autocracy invading
the less corrupt autocracy in this way really
doesn't make any sense.
And you know, let's let's dig into this a
little bit more.
Whether we call something a democracy is very
binary.
The point is, there are major issues in Ukraine,
major issues with the rule of law, major issues
with the Administration of Justice in Ukraine.
Women's rights are kind of a disaster in Ukraine.
Freedom of expression.
Hate crimes are out of control in Ukraine.
You know, the real serious issues in Ukraine.
But number one, those issues are worse in
Russia.
But that's kind of what about ism?
So let's not even focus on that.
It's it's kind of weird for Tucker to justify
Russia's invasion of Ukraine over things that
Russia has a worse record on.
But in a sense, it's what about ism?
The real issue is Tucker implicitly invalidating
Ukraine's sovereignty and saying Putin can
decide what happens in Ukraine if Putin decides
that Ukraine is corrupt.
Putin can invade.
That's really the issue.
The implied point is that Ukraine isn't even
a democracy, so therefore it's OK for Putin
to invade.
Everything he says about Ukraine applies to
Russia 10 times over.
Is Russia a democracy?
Is Putin not corrupt?
Is there freedom of the press in Russia?
Come on, come on.
And the U.S. propaganda machine sails full
speed ahead.
And it to some degree, I feel like we don't
even have like a real defense against this
type of propaganda.
It's it.
It has pervaded, and so many people are literally
rooting for Putin and Russia here and against
Joe Biden, which which is a very strange way
of showing how America first you are as they
claim to be.
Also funny is that the right wingers accusing
Ukraine of not being a democracy are the people
who have been accepting Trump's efforts to
undermine American democracy.
I mean, the number of hypocrisies and contradictions
is stunning.
The very same people who, despite Joe Biden
winning in 2020, said, Well, I don't know
that really one, and it would have been fine
for Pence to overturn it.
It would have been fine for the rioters to
prevent the certification to try to give Trump
another opportunity.
It would have been fine for states to send
alternate electors as Arizona and some other
states were thinking of doing as part of the
so-called Green Bay sweep.
They have undermined American democracy at
every opportunity, and now we're justifying
Putin's invasion of Ukraine by saying, Well,
Ukraine's not really a democracy.
Come on.
Now, think back to the second Iraq War in
2003.
In 2003, when people like me were saying this
war doesn't make any sense, we shouldn't be
doing this.
This is a terrible idea.
You Iraq didn't even have weapons of mass
destruction.
The entire intelligence case made for going
into Iraq is bogus.
These right wingers were saying, You're rooting
against America.
You're rooting against our troops.
You're defending Saddam.
And they were wrong.
Of course, Saddam was a bad guy, but things
were relatively stable geopolitically with
his presence in Iraq.
But he didn't have anything to do with nine
eleven and he didn't have weapons of mass
destruction.
We weren't rooting against the U.S.
We were saying, let's not even get involved
in this.
Those people who said, you're rooting against
the U.S., they are literally defending and
supporting Putin now.
And we saw clips from from Tucker.
There are clips from Hannity.
Here's one other bizarre clip from last night's
Tucker Carlson show, where he says he sent
a letter to both the Russian and Ukrainian
presidents, as well as to Congressman David
Cicilline.
And that Cicilline is repulsive, but hopefully
he'll agree to be interviewed like it's beyond
parody.
Speaker 5: So today we sent another letter
to Vladimir Putin asking for an interview,
right?
We get it.
We also send a message to the president of
Ukraine.
We would like that interview to OK.
Now, neither one of these men runs a democracy
by traditional American standards.
Both of them are tyrants.
True.
But they're in the news, and we would love
to talk to them.
An interview is hardly an endorsement.
In that same spirit, we've also reached out
to Congressman Cicilline, his office, inviting
him on this show.
David Cicilline is a former mafia lawyer who
represents one of our most corrupt states.
He is a repulsive man.
Is it immoral to talk to him?
No, it's not immoral.
It would be interesting.
And so we hope Congressman Cicilline accepts
our invitation.
Speaker 1: I mean, it's beyond parody.
The congressman is a repulsive man, and we
hope that he accepts our invitation to be
interviewed.
We've dealt with booking what we might call
hostile or adversarial guests.
One of the things we never do is to say we
find you repulsive in asking for the interview.
It's I. It's just I know Tucker has a whole
team of people over there.
I would suggest not violently with rhetoric,
but not physically attacking the character
of the people that you're trying to interview
will have these clips on our Instagram if
you're just listening today.
Find us on Instagram at David Pakman Show.